when harry met sally's ending was
altered because the director found love
the t-rex in jurassic park wasn't meant
to finish off the show
what other movies had dramatically
changed endings and why stay tuned to
find out
directed and co-written by shane black
2018's the predator ends with the heroes
finding a way to defeat the invading
extraterrestrials thanks to some alien
tech called the predator killer it's an
obvious setup for a sequel but the
original script ended with a much cooler
stinger in black and fred decker's
screenplay the movie ends shortly after
the ragtag crew defeats the ultimate
predator quinn mckenna his son rory and
biologist casey brackett have all
survived the battle but their adventures
aren't quite over yet
a helicopter shows up and who should
step out of the chopper but dutch
schaefer himself
the muscle-bound mercenary played by
arnold schwarzenegger in the original
film dutch tells the survivors that they
need to come with him
that's when little rory asks me too and
dutch responds especially you that's
where the film ends implying that rory
will be essential in the war against the
predators
unfortunately black couldn't manage to
book schwarzenegger for such a small
part as the actor explained to yahoo in
2017
they asked me and i read it and i didn't
like it whatever they offered so i'm not
going to do that no except if there's a
chance that they rewrite it or make it a
more significant role stick around
one of the all-time great rom-coms when
harry met sally features billy crystal
and meg ryan caught in a will they won't
day friendship that spans years they
finally get together on new year's eve
making for the perfect ending to a
brilliant love story
but things were originally going to be a
lot more melancholy in nora ephron's
screenplay the two lose touch for a few
years and at the end they reunite for a
few brief moments catching up one last
time before parting ways again
that all changed when director rob
reiner found love
he was dealing with some heavy personal
issues while making the film and as he
explained to people tv in 2018 i was
single for 10 years and making a mess of
my personal life in and out of
relationships and not being able to make
anything work but then while shooting
the film reiner met the woman who would
become his wife michelle singer
that radically altered his outlook on
everything including the ending of when
harry met sally caught in the swells of
romance reiner changed the finale during
the film thereby allowing harry and
sally to wind up together because when
you realize you want to spend the rest
of your life with somebody you want the
rest of your life to start as soon as
possible
while the name rambo has become
virtually synonymous with action movie
heroes from the 80s sylvester stallone's
one man army was nearly brought to a
definitive end in his debut film 1982's
first blood followed the vietnam war
veteran as he was targeted by an
overbearing small town sheriff leading
to an escalating conflict that saw rambo
outmaneuver the national guard and elude
authorities this showdown culminated
with rambo using a machine gun to shoot
up buildings throughout town before
being confronted by his old commanding
officer colonel troutman the original
ending mirrored the novel by david
morrell in which troutman shoots rambo
dead though in the film it's rambo who
manually forces his old friend to pull
the trigger effectively killing himself
though this ending was filmed and
included as a deleted scene on the home
video release director ted kochef told
entertainment weekly in 2017 that both
he and stallone felt the original
conclusion was too grim then they
conceived a new ending with rambo
surrendering to troutman
one of the most heartbreaking scenes in
star trek history is the death of mr
spock at the end of 1982's star trek ii
the wrath of khan in the film's climax
spock heroically sacrifices his life to
repair the enterprise's warp drive
thereby allowing it to escape the
genesis weapon as he's dosed with lethal
radiation however the movie ends with
strong hints that audiences haven't seen
the last of spock how do we know if you
notice his coffin is seen on the newly
formed genesis planet while the
character narrates the famous star trek
intro monologue
these are the continuing voyages
of the starship
enterprise
but originally wrath of khan lacked this
more hopeful conclusion with spock's
death appearing more definitive but then
co-writer harv bennett devised the
expanded more uplifting ending
post-production included reshoots on the
genesis planet with leonard nimoy
recording the monologue director
nicholas meyer objected to these changes
but ultimately to no avail
terminator 2 judgement day is one of
those rare sequels that outdoes its
predecessor as director james cameron
reunited with his main cast to make the
ultimate sci-fi action movie as a
teenager john connor finds himself
hunted by an even more advanced killing
machine from the future his mother sarah
reluctantly teams up with a repurposed
t-800 to protect him and humanity's
eventual salvation rather than leave
room for seemingly endless sequels to
exploit t2 originally concluded with a
definitive happy ending for the connor
family in the film sarah experiences a
nightmare where she witnesses a
playground full of children get
violently incinerated by a nuclear blast
this scene set up the originally
intended ending with an older sarah
serenely watching an adult john playing
with his daughter at a similar
playground after the early screening
producer stephanie austin revealed to
den of geek in 2017 that it was
determined this original ending didn't
resonate as well as hoped so in the
spirit of creating something more
evocative the altered ending with the
open road was ultimately used for the
final cut instead
the danny boyle directed zombie thriller
28 days later sees humans infected by
pure rage overrunning great britain over
the course of a month following the
widespread social collapse a young man
named jim awakens alone in a deserted
london hospital shocked at what has
happened to the world while he was in a
coma
in the theatrical ending he and his
fellow survivors are able to flag a
passing aircraft suggesting that they
may have lived long enough to escape
this post-apocalyptic hellscape just
thank you serious this time
however jim wasn't always intended to
survive the events of the film with
several different planned endings
featuring his untimely demise
one version that was shot saw him
succumb to gunshot wounds that he
endured in the climax with his friends
selena and hannah leaving him behind
another ending which didn't progress
beyond the animatic stage featured jim
sacrificing himself by offering a
complete blood transfusion to hannah's
infected father in order to cleanse him
of the contagion
one of the biggest action blockbusters
of all time jurassic park opened to rave
reviews and earned well over 900 million
dollars at the worldwide box office
during its initial theatrical run in
1993 based on the best-selling michael
crichton novel of the same name the film
is set on a theme park populated by
cloned dinosaurs that descends into
chaos after it gets overrun by its own
prehistoric attractions as
paleontologists alan grant and ellie
sadler lead two children to safety
they're rescued in the nick of time by a
t-rex who attacks the velociraptors that
are menacing them but in the original
ending instead of being conveniently
saved by a t-rex seemingly out of
nowhere the humans were forced to fend
for themselves
storyboards from the scrapped version
had the survivors maneuvering the
raptors into dinosaur skeletons
displayed in the visitor center and
killing them with the sharp heavy bones
ultimately the filmmakers decided to
give the t-rex the big moment instead
after being impressed by just how
powerful the creature's depiction became
during production
titanic was a phenomenal box office
success but it was also a major change
of pace for director james cameron as he
eschewed his penchant for action in
favor of a tragic period peace romance
the plot is framed by a treasure hunter
named brock lovett who explores the
wreckage of the title ship with one of
the few surviving passengers rose
calvert
rose recounts a whirlwind love story she
had before the ill-fated ocean liner
sank
after recalling her experience rose
drops the priceless diamond that brock
was searching for into the ocean leaving
him unaware that she had it the whole
time cameron had originally written and
filmed an ending scene in which rose's
granddaughter lizzie and brock witnessed
rose disposing of the diamond as a way
to resolve the fortune seeker's
character arc in this alternate version
rose allows brock to hold the diamond
before tossing it into the ocean as he
admits the treasure doesn't matter in
the grand scheme of life but cameron
ultimately felt the audience wouldn't be
invested in brock's character arc
following the extended flashback and
bill paxton who played brock agreed with
the decision
three years
i've thought of nothing except titanic
but i never got it
steven spielberg returned to the
blockbuster world of dinosaurs with the
1997 sequel the lost world jurassic park
the movie features the nefarious injen
corporation deciding to take dinosaurs
from isla sorna to a planned theme park
in california the survivors of this
expedition narrowly escape isla sorna
with their lives but then they must
contend with the t-rex rampaging through
the streets of san diego upon their
return this version of the finale was
suggested by spielberg five weeks before
the start of principal photography which
necessitated a rewrite from the original
ending
the original conclusion featured the
survivors escaping the island only to
face a pterodactyl in a high-flying
fight espielberg told time magazine he
envisioned dinosaurs invading the
mainland for an eventual third jurassic
park film however when he realized that
he was unlikely to helm such a project
he decided to have some fun while
directing the changed ending
2016's rogue one a star wars story
explored the events that set the
original star wars trilogy in motion an
outgunned rebel alliance makes a daring
raid on the remote imperial planet of
scarif as they obtain the plans to the
galactic empire secret weapon the death
star though successful in transmitting
the data to the rest of the alliance the
intrepid squad is wiped out when the
death star fires on their location on
scarif while the creative team always
envisioned protagonists jyn erso and
cassian andor heroically sacrificing
themselves for the alliance's greater
victory another ending was actually
planned as screenwriter gary widow
revealed to entertainment weekly
aversions sparing gin and cassian was
written in case disney thought that
killing off both the film's lead
characters would be considered too dark
fortunately lucasfilm president kathleen
kennedy decided to stick with the
original plan ultimately the team agreed
with the decision to leave the entire
squad to their p rick victory on scarif
the 2017 horror flick get out marked
jordan peel's shift from tv sketch
comedy to cinematic thrills with academy
award-winning success the plot follows a
young man named chris who visits his
girlfriend rose's parents for the first
time in a remote upstate new york town
only to discover that this community has
a twisted secret as it turns out rose's
family and their neighbors take control
of black people's bodies in a bid for
immortality
in the version of the ending that played
in theaters chris kills rose's family
and successfully escapes as he's picked
up by his friend rod a tsa agent but in
another version that was filmed chris is
discovered by the police instead who
arrest him on the spot for murdering
rose in apparent cold blood
in an oral history published by vulture
peel noted that test audiences reacted
poorly to that vision so he decided to
give get out a happier conclusion
instead as he put it when i realized the
original downer ending wasn't working i
didn't freak out i looked at it as an
opportunity to come up with a better
ending i mean i told you not to go in
that house
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]